so you're about to watch one of the
first ever
over-the-board duck chess videos I've
ever recorded and this was filmed over a
month ago I was in Toronto for the
chess.com Global championships and I
ended up uh being in a room with a bunch
of other big chess celebrities and
Grandmasters
um including Gotham chess Daniel
nerdinsky uh Fabiano carvana and Danny
wrench and James Canty were in the
background uh playing some other version
of Chess but in this video you're going
to see a duck chess game that starts
between nariditsky and Gotham chess and
we were using a small rubber ducky and
uh Gotham just got a losing position
really quickly and just resigned and
then I offered to take over his losing
position and try and fight back and it
ended up being some really funny content
and if you're not familiar with duck
chess the rules are pretty simple to
understand the duck acts as a blocker so
can't be captured Can't Be Moved Through
and with every turn we uh make a normal
move and then move the duck to a new
empty square and it adds a lot more uh a
lot more interesting strategy and
quaktics which uh I think even Grand
Masters are not used to so I really hope
you enjoyed the video uh don't forget to
like And subscribe if you want to see
more duck chess leave a comment let me
know your thoughts and let's get to the
duck chess
wait what am I why am I putting my duck
on my sideboard that's actually like not
that bad you can sabotage yourself
conduct we found the same square two
times no you have to move it to a new
Square put it on your own Square
so a common opening is G3 duck G2 and
then your guaranteed positions
exactly 29 30. 31 32 I can 35 oh 34.
[Music]
I went I went sooner than he did
recently yeah
you can Castle
through the docs
the body wasn't meant to do this
it's science brother
wasn't meant to be like this
what am I doing this is so stupid
43 44 oh my God 45.
again what I'm just okay
oh man
loser what a loser
all right well we're losing that would
just you know keep going
okay I don't have a rook for somebody
I got two minutes and ten more push-ups
that would be a queen
I I think I'll do the push-ups
it's very slow very very poor
performance but okay
I'll I'll jump in with you I think the
game wow
push-ups and
shots
I mean
it's from personal experience
all right ready yeah
you're you're like a tricky little guy
foreign
but what is that
is
okay that's the new game
I might call in the hotel just drinking
push-ups I heard poker night 51 52 53
54.
59 60.
all right now even time too much
we're all squared up you're on your own
here you're absolutely right you are
absolutely right now
[Music]
these are the true facts you've been
spitting all night man
you know I gotta play real chess against
5v1 of pariano
real chess I need
a real chess
a real chess
underestimates me
yeah
never good enough okay for Fabiano
cariano
yeah what happened to Sarah one that day
yeah Johan this is a really epic
pronunciation
um
okay you can't beat blood
you can't make one I see it inside of
you
smoky
man I'm so resentful there's increment
on that clock I'll tell you what man
Chester
I see what you're doing bro yeah
what is it
your ideas are going to get you in
trouble one day Bobby
and you said I'm following my dreams Mom
I don't want to be like that so annoying
but you actually wanted all my pieces
I hate this brother comes back oh you're
clean oh who's winning
oh that was a great position for me you
were you're fine with equalized I'm
increment come on come on come on Daddy
I was winning there before the case